mr depp do you recall miss heard
testifying that she you did not assist
her in getting her role in aquaman
uh yes i do yes
and what is your response to that it's
not exactly true after
ms heard's uh
audition or possibly auditions
for warner brothers and the
i suppose the creative team
um
mr
expressed to me that
the
film was going to be warner brothers had
said the film was going to be shooting
in australia
and australia was a
for misheard that was a potential
problem because there it was of concern
um
to warner brothers
um
so she asked if i would
because i i had a i'd had a
a multi
um
for a few years i'd had a multi-film
uh deal with with warner brothers and uh
so we'd been in business together so
i knew
these people i've been in i've been on
films with them
so i
she asked me if i would speak to them
i made a phone call and i i spoke to uh
objection hearsay your honor
i i don't believe he said anything he i
think he was going to say who he spoke
to all right let's see overruled at this
point
um
i spoke to
three um the three upper echelon
um
disney executive excuse me warner
executives
kevin tsujihara sue krull
and uh
greg silverstein
um
and i
told them objection your honor hearsay
all right also standing objection next
question
um what was the result of you speaking
with those individuals
i can only say that ultimately she did
she did get the
job in the film can you please show the
jury where you were sitting when
misheard threw um the two vodka bottles
at you
um
if i touch this thing we'll make a yes
as well okay
so
this shared
that one
here was over here
and and it was in pretty much when i was
turned around toward the wrong swivel so
when i was turned around towards the bar
i'm facing the bar when i turned around
this way the chair
this chair here was
in
uh
pretty much exactly this same position
as this chair
it was fake when i was facing
um miss her
who was
let's say she was
if you're looking at the photograph she
would be about here
could you uh draw a line in the
direction where miss hurt was relative
to where you were sitting yes absolutely
so
if i'm sitting here
um
she was over here
like back here
approximately how far away from his
heard
from
you was miss hurt if you can recall
i would say
i would say it was probably
10 12 15 feet maybe
10 feet 12 feet
and
approximately where was your hand when
the vodka bottle hit it
it was um
it was leaning
my arm wasn't sorry
my arm was leaning on the um
the marble bar
right there where that the imaginary see
this
and uh
leaning
and kind of just leaning back and and um
looking at miss heard she just walked
away with the the second bottle
uh well i mean she walked this way when
she threw the first bottle which is
uh
actually visible
in the background
could you please circle where the first
bottle oh sorry excuse me
all that is the um
exploded first bottle
that
went past my
it went past my head
and the second bottle
hit
right up here where my hand was resting
on the um
marble bar where did you and miss her go
on your honeymoon
um
we we um took the
the orient express
um
from
bangkok
thailand to singapore
and
what happened while you and miss heard
were together on the orient express
um
there were there were times when it was
very
agreeable very nice
and then there were
times when
um
something some
something
had become dissatisfactory for her and
she would uh
start the
the um
rant
the blooming of the
of a fight
would be on deck there and uh
at one point
it didn't i mean i don't remember
lasting long at all i i just remember
that um
i took a pretty good uh
shot to the
um
to the face to the eye to somewhere up
here
so i had a bit of a
shiner mr depp what if any injuries do
you see
on your face in this photograph
i see pretty much the same i i
i see that
the the area in here has been um well is
and uh
um yeah there's a bit of a shiner there
thank you we can take this down
mr depp do you recall miss heard
testifying that she
punched you um in the staircase incident
because she thought of miss kate moss in
the stairs
do i remember saying that
yes i do three times
yes i do
do you have any understanding as to what
miss heard was referring to
i yes i do
um
[Music]
as as kate
moss um kate testified
it was many many years ago
um
and what exactly what
happened is
what she said happened
i
uh
recall i recall
um
speaking with ms heard about and
that in that very incident
um
because of
the down downpouring of rain because it
was raining very heavily that day that
kate slipped
uh
and i recalled the story to her i'll
make it easy for mr
rotten
born
mr
took the story
and
turned it into
[Music]
a very ugly incident
all in her
mind
there was never
a moment
where i pushed kate down any set of
stairs
yet she's spewed this three times before
uh objection your honor misheard simply
testified that she had heard a rumor and
that's what responds to the question sir
hold on subjection
um
so what what specifically had you
actually told miss heard about
the incident with miss moss and the
stairs
very simply that she had
we were in jamaica
um
i had left our bungalow
um
about three minutes prior to her i was
standing outside and
suddenly rain starts just coming down
like it's you know
a monsoon and then i remember looking
and seeing kate
coming out the door
and there were three little
wooden stairs and she slipped her legs
went up
and she landed directly on her coccyx
and her lower back
so
and she was obviously physically
in pain and
she was hurt she was crying so i ran
over
and grabbed her to make you know to make
sure she was all right but i
have never
in my life
committed
sexual battery
physical abuse
all these
outlandish outrageous stories
of me committing these things
and living with it for six years
and waiting to be able to
bring
the truth
out
so this is not uh
easy for any of us
i know that
but um uh
no matter what happens i did get here
and i did tell the truth and i
have
spoken
up
for
what i've been
carrying on my back
reluctantly
for six years